why people don't if you like if people
say well I had never thought about it
that way or they'd say no no surely this
is what self is the self is our
individuality or it's our genes yeah
watch some sort of inherited trait or
something like that I think one is
because that those are straightforwardly
those are the messages that we get
through the newspapers there's a lot of
stuff about you know genetic structure
as they will people behave in some very
predetermined biological genetic kind of
way also I think people often answer
these things very individualistic we
because we live in a relatively
individualistic society which tells us
actually where it's all about you the
individual it's all about me and I and
and and so there's an ideological and a
kind of an everyday sense to that did
you know I was just walking on the way
here today I was walking through a
shopping mall and it's all about you and
making you as an individual feel special
actually the evidence is that case I use
is over it was recently a BBC journalist
who went to live on his own in
wilderness for five years and actually
what he found was actually apart from
becoming chronically depressed he lost
any sense of identity because he wasn't
connected to other people so it's one of
those I mean the point there is that the
everyday understandings that we have
about things are just often wrong ok now
the job of social science is to sort of
demonstrate why they're wrong and try to
get them right and I would say why is
our work not more influential because in
sense we you know we haven't bridged all
those gaps we haven't sold we haven't
done all the research we haven't
necessarily been as effective at
convincing our colleagues or and getting
that message out to society which is
what higher precisely why I think it's
so important to engage in events and
activities like this because again i
think i think that knowledge is there in
the social science community at least a
part of it but actually it's not one
that people routine you're given access
to and there are good reasons for that
people who run shops don't want you to
think that actually shopping is bad for
you in the long term and having a
materialistic identity is only going to
make you more depressed but the evidence
is it probably will you should stop
shopping going to them all time with
your family